hey guys we need your help we need good
video editors so if you are a good video
editor and you want to help us to share
the gospel effectively to all people in
all nations then please reach out to us
especially if you're a mature Christian
because it does help you to edit the
videos better because you understand the
word um of course we're not going to
know everything because we're all
growing in Christ but if you pray about
it and you know this is what God wants
you to do then please reach out to us
and use your skills for God's glory
reach out to us today if your editing is
really good if God has blessed you with
creativity and um speed and
Effectiveness to share his gospel in a
different way we need you reach out to
us
today